[Music]
that was there's still no fade into that
at all absolutely none but that's okay
hi everyone how's it going I'm Ben mrs.
Persia and we're here playing the Call
of Duty 2 v2 gunfight alpha I think
that's the official title it actually
went live early yesterday and we all got
a chance to kind of play a bit but today
we're streaming it so you guys can see
it maybe you can try to queue up at the
same time as us and get into it I don't
know how but usually this is community
Fridays you don't really have much
control over an alpha but I'm gonna stop
talking and we can get into playing the
game because I know that you that's the
outro that you hit when you're you're
trying to be done and this is what you
hit when you want to see the gameplay
it's right I'm already botching it oh
man yeah I'm excited for this actually I
think a lot of people in general
yeah yeah taking it back to some you
know fundamental Cod play but it's been
feeling good so far yeah I've been
having a good time with it too I kind of
like the the speed of it where it's it
feels like it's not as fast as a regular
Call of Duty maybe it's just this
game-mode cuz you've got to be more
careful while you're playing the to be
to you oh boy okay so every round I
think it's like every two rounds you get
a new loadout yeah but everyone starts
the same lowdown looks like you're
starting off with an m14 and an auto
rifle of sorts this is the part that I'm
excited for because it's called duty and
the only time sound happens is when
someone shoots so I'm gonna try to level
this volume but yeah Tino brings up an
excellent point and interesting effect a
battlefield is better they say and yeah
I've always been kind of a little bit
more of a battlefield guy myself but I'm
excited for this because they've got a
lot of weird battlefield influence isn't
it before before we went live we're
actually talking about
they've got like 20 v20 mode with
vehicles in it and it seems like they're
kind of going after battlefields deal
because battlefield is kind of in a
weird place right now so um I'm excited
to play this game and see what they do
to kind of step into that space
I mean we're also talking about how you
know nothing feels more intuitive than
just picking up a card game like yeah
you know exactly what you're doing
and they always feel good like the
shooting in the aiming and call of duty
has always been fantastic regardless of
like the content or updates servers or
anything it just feels good to kind of
like play of call duty game yes police
this is a 2v2 mode with he's on the move
random will not random changing loadouts
Oh a back flip britain place okay my
audio is not working the Alpha I need
help
maybe there's like an audio setting on
your PlayStation that might be kind of
moved around maybe I had like popping at
some point but I've never had it like
drop out of oh dang hello on the UH the
wheat emblems are back in full effects
is definitely a thing to address right
away a lot of people going in the chat
right now and I assume it's because
you're all excited to play banjo-kazooie
and smash man that thing actually put a
bigger smile on my face and seeing
everyone's reactions oh my god i i i did
there was too much for me because that
whole week i'd been like scouring the
internet for e3 leaks on what was gonna
happen to smash
there you go and there's so much so much
kind of like leading up to it just
seeing it actually happened was was too
much I couldn't take it man me and my
Ipsy me are doing pretty good in this
round
hey crime and Bob Jones good to see ya
Crump says John looks different today we
got we got an expert in in today it's do
some some sweet Call of Duty expert as I
get my face blown off hey this is the
thing like all those all those
professional Call of Duty players and
all that they don't win a hundred
percent of time you can't win one
hundred percent of time it's when you
make those those good plays that the the
high IQ moves banjo kazooie what I want
to see is we got we got Luigi's Mansion
three coming out
we got Luigi is like a cannon character
that was a trade yeah dang or did the
other guy get me dang you ever die in
your own round winning killcam there you
go
but we got we got GUI G as a cannon
character who's like in Luigi's Mansion
I want to see banjo kazooie as a
character that comes in when we get
banjo three what's gonna happen Kirk I'm
also glad that kinky rules and smash
that's one that I feel like a lot of
people wanted for a long time and me
right there with you
I'm happy that more rare characters are
showing up anyway I'm gonna keep talking
about smash while we're playing call of
duty because that's definitely how our
Fridays dreams go we don't really talk
about exactly what we're playing so we
just kind of hang out and Tang a66 over
to for the first match she didn't even
think about it just breezing right
through it
sniper and this game is top notch yeah
the sniper feels really good to use and
I'm not a person who ever uses sniper
rifles and calls
because I'm not very good with them but
I'm able to do stuff with it in this one
so yeah I feel like the shotguns I've
used so far are also pretty good yeah
yeah Krum says I've been looking at this
game since no battlefield this year and
it's got Crossway that's true that's a
really big thing Call of Duty is gonna
have cross play this year that's wild
that's pretty epic though yeah yeah and
I'm glad that more games are embracing
that cross play for sure so we got a lot
of fighting games that are kind of like
doing it we've got Call of Duty's
breaking into it
that will be announced this week that
battlegrounds is going to be
cross-platform at least we've seen a lot
of this game this weekend yeah see and
if you wait too long there's like an
overtime flag that you can cap there's a
lot of stuff that kind of just moves
this mode forward which is cool I
appreciate that this person didn't go
with the wheat emblem they went with the
t-rex yeah police knows this is it full
game early release no this is just like
a like I guess it's kind of a technical
alpha they're trying to test connections
and stuff by letting people play a 2v2
gunfight mode which is what they kind of
showed off mostly not not the full game
by any means but still kind of a cool
way to get your hands on the game and
feel what it
please dang nice nailed it
ice wants to know what her favorite
smash characters are you give a smash
character you kind of yo see yo she's
good I kind of it's gonna be banjo
coming up but I still like years after
they announced it and he's been in two
games I still can't believe snake is in
there I love him to death
there's no right being in there choking
out Mario but there is that Donkey Kong
K rool I love all my rare characters
they knew what they were feeling it
Jeffrey says this game looks a lot more
meteor like in quotations and I get what
you're kind of saying like everything
feels a bit heavier and kind of has like
more impact and I definitely agree and
I'm very into that mr. Harrison saying
that pistol play is sick sweet kicks I
was like oh no I have like one more
bullet in this clip my teammate I saw a
crime ask if you if you gave yuccas a
try yeah
doesn't that much time between the last
time we talked about it and now but is
that is that still a finger you're
thinking about
we got focus mode it's happening but but
I saw the I saw the murder happened oh
there's the other person of course
Bowser's grave oh yeah anytime there's a
run with a rocket launcher I have to
start off with the rocket launch I'm
trying to get to it and across the map
it's almost it's almost as good as
getting a melee kill I feel like it's
it's very insulting oh my goodness
dang this guns so clunky yeah nailed it
Richie's in the chat what up Richie
how's it going rich he really wanted to
complain yeah I talked to you about it
last night like I can't like not try to
get Ritchie on a Call of Duty stream
like that that's like it's like doing a
Metal Gear stream without me on it or
like okay yeah cuz a stream without me
on it but uh yeah he's rich you had to
had things you had to do so
unfortunately you're stuck with me -
nice I tried to get my was worried I was
gonna drag you down definitely make it
so that you weren't gonna win as much
and also I I liked having kind of
someone to kind of anchor and talk to
the chat a bit it's it's important to be
able to talk talk to you guys how
different is gunplay I mean it feels
obviously pretty odd like they do a good
job at that but also I feel like
everything's a little more
[Music]
realistic yeah like that's one thing in
other cops I was like man this gun
definitely has way more recoil than this
like in real life and stuff like that
it's like just overpowered but I feel
like this being in that guy got she's
got behind me Oh Flo brings up a really
good thing to the leaning I totally
forgot about leaving my entire time
playing yesterday I think it has to be
like a more more specific maybe oh god
there's rushed it we were too busy
trying to show off a leaning which wants
to know about the overall gun feel since
they'll have a ps4 and they can't play
the guns feel good I like it I do
someone mentioned earlier that the the
gameplay just kind of feels meteor like
everything everything has more and more
weight to it which I'm really into
that's the other thing they've got like
four different aim assists in this I saw
a yeah not not like a professional Cod
player but someone who who does a lot of
kind of like competitive shooting games
and they recommended actually using the
enhanced auto aim which sounds like it's
a real cheating way to do it but what it
does is it like I guess it slows down
your 80s more and it makes it much
easier to kind of like track on things
don't know if you want to try that but I
don't know I already play on a pretty
low sensitivity yeah yeah I don't think
the reason I do play on low density is
to like help my aim yeah
stay steady but I've known people play
on like 10 cents civvy I'm like I don't
know how because I think the because the
the enhanced one the way that it was
being described is like for people who
play on a higher sensitivity because it
it lowers the ADEs aiming so much more
so you're able to still get like those
whip around when you're like not a
de-essing but then as soon as you bring
it in you're able to kind of follow
through which is you know definitely a
thing any time getting shot in the back
my first things like run to cover and
then third darkmount slow I can't really
like
we call slow that is yeah helps with aim
though Kevin says when you lean you
don't really peek with your gun it shows
your whole body that's not good sounds
counterproductive yeah I haven't seen it
used much yet and I definitely haven't
used it yet because I'd totally forgot
about it but I've been sliding around
and doing all that stuff is good do you
think this game oh wow do you like
Batman's you like jumping off of the
rafters this game looks and sounds like
the same old Cod slark ad not immersive
at all
I feel like it's more grounded in
reality than previous Call of Duty's but
yeah it still got that kind of subtly
rkd kind of flow to it Adam heck yeah
see here
these are on takes so much easier when
you get like an automatic weapon or
happy I feel like that's that's kind of
what it is like the the switching
weapons kind of gives everyone a chance
like have a good set arounds because
like I wouldn't do well on this one cuz
I don't use like marksman rifles at all
but as soon as that that submachine gun
round pops up you know that I'm gonna
get at least a killer - do you think
this game in the future would bring back
some classic fan favorite call duty maps
for nostalgia I'm pretty sure this is
like a bit of a throwback I feel like
they're supposed to be kind of
channeling a lot of Call of Duty for
maps it seems or at least I feel like
yeah
I personally seem like yeah also if I
were using this gun I definitely have
like like a red dot on it or like a
holographic sight I wouldn't use the
iron sights personally a flashbang or
something I don't know what I injected
my is a little bit yeah that's like a
feeling syringe or something
that makes sense yeah yeah recovering
your life and this one takes longer
crime says to be honest I'm more
interested in the big modes like a 20/20
I'm right there with you cuz like I
played this one like cool I'm gonna get
a feel for the new Call of Duty and as I
played more and more of it I was just
kind of like man I wish I could play
like some deathmatch sure like some some
control or whatever or try out the new
mode like that's that's what I want to
do
poolman where is so the guy now
hide-and-seek you are not control
controls the one into dance I've been
thinking a lot about destiny recently
I'm sorry
now you whole buddy but you got it right
like in the chest do you think the lads
supply drops into the game I have no
idea I kind of hope they don't cuz that
that's really turned me off of the last
couple of games oh yeah I should mention
if any of you want to try this to be too
big yeah that's pretty good if any of
you guys want to try this it's it's free
for everyone I think with PS plus or
maybe without PS plus but it's you don't
have to pre order to get access to it
it's kind of meant to be like a stress
test I think so tell your friends tell
them to download it see what you can get
together and play some party I guess I
don't even know you can you can invite
people this can yeah they just they come
out of nowhere
that jump was like your character was
leaning oh man oh man don't need PS plus
turtle turtles telling me you don't need
PS plus so that's even better
let's get that that download and jump on
in
go within surgery and certain C is a
pretty good time I played a lot more of
like Red Orchestra and stuff because I
like the kind of World War 2 setting but
is the those those games from what's the
company they're good and you can't
invite your friends to play with you
shoot we're getting all the the hot info
I love it yeah I I do appreciate that
I'm able to kind of count on you guys to
help fill in the knowledge gaps from
things that I haven't got a chance to
kind of look at yet this week's been
very busy
just with Gamescom stuff happening all
over the place with this big old clunky
gun yeah yeah see that this is one of
those rounds that I would do pretty well
in because I I love just the big dumb
light machine guns that you can like
shoot at the wall and hope that you get
hits
we're going for it as this available on
PC I believe it's only ps4 at least for
now I don't know if there any other
betas planned for oh man I should have
shoddy Allen I was kind of halfway
committing to it so I tried playing arma
like as ARMA is and I can see a lot of
people getting into that and kind of
being down with it but I I really only
got ARMA for playing dayz when it wasn't
mod and I played a bit of like I played
a couple of missions my god watch that
one where'd that shot come from that's
right it's just one on one it's not even
that big of a thing you were carrying to
look at you with the two more kills than
your teammate
I like that tells you how much damage
you did - I think that's a nice touch
yeah and I'm kind of digging someone
mentioned the the more minimalist HUD
and I'm kind of into it like it lets me
kind of find things at a quick glance
and I don't need to kind of worry about
it taking up too much space but I like
it
we back up I'm trying to find same
people or not what's your opinion on
ARMA I like what it's trying to do but
it's it might be a little bit over my
head
I like the sandbox that it lets you kind
of tool around in a lot but yeah I'm not
I'm not as much as I like to be like oh
yeah I'm a cool tactical thinker I love
playing Rainbow six in Splinter Cell the
armors on a whole new level and I can't
like I can't do it dang some people are
just right who did this you have a good
tongue kid get excited it's the weekend
we all get to play Call of Duty for free
you got the awesome cool thing you're
doing anyway
yeah that's why I'm excited we get to
play today yeah yeah there we go
please play life is strange - I haven't
I fell off of the life of strange after
the first one and I kind of want to go
back into it but we're probably not
gonna be playing any life is strange
today unfortunately but maybe sometime
not a good Armour player but it's fun
with friend yeah I I can see that like I
had fun messing around with it I like
the UH like I said I did it for the the
dayz mod and then I also kind of did it
a little bit to mess around with the
like we had role-playing server things
was kind of cool
like I said the sandbox for those games
is phenomenal but I'm not very good
about the high he's not even there you
got abandoned all right
try to memorize all the key bindings in
our line man he didn't even like go up
to try to check his went for the the
kill is it true the modern warfare will
have a battle royale mode you'll be free
to play I haven't heard anything about
that I don't think that would be the
case if they were to do that I'm pretty
sure probably be bundled in with the
game heck and crazier things have
happened banjos and smash what nothing's
off-limits
come on Sammy boy he's not that real
cool emblem though this is me moving
them right now well that's yeah
interesting you're like like spiritually
possessing here like I can do this will
it be ranked mode co2 seems perfect for
ranked eSports I think that's what the
kind of mentality for this this mode is
so I feel like it's cuz yeah this this
is very eSports E and they're putting on
very eSports e maps that are kind of
like the symmetrical they've got similar
things on both sides can going for them
the there's an even playing field with
the the weapon swaps and loadout swaps
the time to kill is very good I'm also a
fan of that
oh you get Cod points for your pre-order
so that means supply drops are still
there Oh gross what if they just made it
so that you leveled up and you got all
your stuff through doing challenges like
the older games some 35 gigs too much
for smoke the there are a few guns III
can't rationalize out the the file size
but yeah that does seem kind of big for
just one mode I saw the name flash for a
second yeah this is this is just a
practice round anyway cuz it's not even
like your dudes still not there got up
to go like make a sandwich or something
he's having a rough time dang he's back
he means business let's see if we can
bring it all the way back now
we're we're somewhere yeah the the
challenges in working towards the
prestige stuff and having like ah you
can tell this person really likes using
this gun because they have like a high
level camo for it like that kind of
thing can um find this guy it's a ninja
oh man
alright let you bring it back six
straight around see this is this is the
last round to bring it back so it's good
baby showed up flying through the air
the physics are are wild in this though
sure someone trying to smoke up oh it
was clean throwing grenades
scheisse yes
she's ready for it though alright it's
fine and then he quit looks you know the
one thing that really matters in these
alphas where stats don't get tracked is
your KD and your win-loss because it's
gonna be a thing that's definitely carry
over to something and you're gonna be
able to brag about it not some people
with some bad microphones interesting
okay that's how you did oh it's so ready
to play we can mute those people heck
yeah
I appreciate whenever a game has a mute
all button yeah
go into the Start menu or anything like
that you can see the other people -
alright hey Sebastian how's it going
pistol rounds are I like there it was
peeking around walls
this guy's got all them accounts down oh
no poke them with the gun doing some
sort of like judo moves like he had like
a combo going on impressed with his
gameplay looks a lot slower more
tactical in previous jobs yeah it's it's
definitely got more of a tactical feel
to it but it's still distinctly Call of
Duty
I think tasting he's trying to snipe us
but it's not working there's probably so
many people playing it'd be nice if we
could like invite people to just do like
a a game like just get four people into
a room and just go with it
can you just split-screen not not miss
alpha say that tried time to search at
the same time yeah exactly you gotta you
gotta wait it out they're really into
that that leaning thing hundred 100
health on 100 health lined up I mean you
can kind of slide it's just nowhere near
as good yeah I do I too kind of like the
slide in this I feel like it's just far
enough to kind of like do a thing oh
they're going right for it this is this
is a bold spicy move and you've been
dodging all those bullets capturing the
flag I love it
snow about the double tap to sprint
faster yes all whoa that was clean I'm
making all sorts of dumb like banjo
kazooie sounds now I'm getting excited
about things need to calm down
oh heck yeah he was actually waiting for
the flag that was so ugly dude it's it
came together in the end
yeah what all the maps look like
paintball courses feel like cuz they're
they're trying to have like the weirds
laid right out I think it's it's kind of
getting like the the classic map design
down like you've got the three lanes
that kind of thing all right well I see
this guy likes it
I know Call of Duty had jumpscares that
was I wasn't prepared dang yikes
actually haven't really played any of
siege the last time so six game I played
a lot over this Vegas Vegas is good
biggest two especially I like 50 hours
of siege which isn't a lot like by
comparison to a lot of people who do
play it
I'm also not oh boy are coming around
they're trying to flank you oh my
goodness it was clean it was perfect it
was flawless there's nothing wrong with
how any of that was executed as far as
I'm concerned you've won the entire
match now you could just have the other
person do the rest of the work that's
fine
oh man probably no no please hey that's
fine it's that's the good thing about
games is you don't have to play them if
they're not like your thing it's it's
cool you you have more time to play yeah
cos of them if you don't play call of
duty you can play y'all if you don't
play Yaka so you could play dong and
rhomboid you know feed on the Rafah
Smash Brothers or something we got banjo
greenbacks I'll never let go of that
every time this gun makes me so heavy
he's got the the animated Reaper emblems
that's that's why he had like the extra
damage oh there you go yeah get in a
monster hunter you got that expansion
coming up soon
are you running this game at 30fps on
ps4 why does it look so good I think
that's just the game because it's I'm
pretty sure it's running 60 right now it
does look pretty good yeah you're played
squad I played a little bit of squad not
a lot but there's a as a person who I
worked with back at my previous place of
employment who is very very into it so I
got to kind of get like the like
secondhand squad experience that was
good let's go do that right up against
that wall there bobbin and Weavin
they're ready for it I think the other
guy that's alive is the camper though
yeah believe in you Giovanni yeah just
keep it up as you know they're gonna run
for it or we could Tyson in to send it
to another round oh no because he's one
health below defeat enemy has more
health they won because he had one
health difference though I mean you know
I thought it was just gonna send us
through another round I was like yeah
I'll do it
psych yeah they do like the health
breakdown I was like oh yeah the gotta
have the same health when I looked up
it's 99 to 100 oh alright back to search
and ding I was ready I was like give me
another round Borderlands is coming up
persona 5 Royale if you haven't played
persona 5 perfect chance to give that a
go
if you play persona 5 or probably to
play Royale anyway cuz you like it that
much but yeah yeah Rob's you're talking
about unreal I wish there was an Unreal
Tournament 2
today still out there trying to match up
it's gonna be impossible if he does so
then then you can't leave the match it's
it's gonna be constantly but you can
stay the whole time
oh so clunky sometimes you don't have
the the guns the the matchup this one is
kind of a weird one I feel like once we
get like two rounds away from ending
this game that's when you guys think
they're cheating yeah all right nice
nice teammate with the carry
I did a whopping 48 damage made it
brings up a good point Unreal Tournament
2004 best game ever
why don't we kid Unreal Tournament 2004
remastered bring back Unreal Tournament
2004 in the year 2019 Rob comes in to
clarify we're saying that that loss was
real not about the Unreal games I got
you but also bring back on real
tournament just invite taste Kim can we
invite maybe well when we get done with
this one let's see if we can invite oh
yeah no that's it's locked in it's in
the bag
see it like for instance this pistol and
right
it feels so impactful to fire it and
that you know they just a really tough
it's got that that Desert Eagle kinda
just so let's Gary where are they I
think my best play that I've had on this
map so far is tricking someone into
following me into that container and
then crawling underneath it in the water
and shooting them as they're trying to
find me right there I even see him when
I was looking around it slowed down a
little bit that's always like wait oh
man
looking all stupid some head call duties
favoring ps4 over Xbox and PC again yeah
there's always those weird exclusivity
deal things but maybe there will be more
parity because of the fact that it's
cross-platform maybe you know it will
work out but hey and if anything you'll
be able to take it out on those ps4
players just by invading the games see
can we play this on ps4 you can right
now this is this is the Alpha it's up
and ready to ready to go everyone misses
you it's true Eric does all the work on
the streams making sure they're they're
working and fine but Eric never gets to
be honest where'd that shot come from
where did it go Eric never gets there
Eric never gets to like enjoy just
playing a game on a stream that was
clean those had to have been a head shot
is free yeah this is uh you don't have
to pre-order to get in you just go and
download it and people were saying that
you don't even need PS plus yeah that's
really really good yeah need to put out
an alpha or beta where they test the
cross plate that's what I want to see I
think it's gonna be kind of
revolutionary for COD to have the
cross-play can't believe this that Lake
curved those bullets were curved and
I think you shot me through the crate
yeah like all the dinosaur calling cards
those are real good all right
yeah 35 gigs this is definitely a hefty
alpha yeah yeah that is a good point the
internet bill for downloading all those
gigs isn't free
it's from someplace katana zero times
zero is a very good game another one
that I like but I'm not very good at how
long is about four I believe this office
was running through the weekend nice
strats God no stop
reevaluate yourself not falling for that
that's that's a baby trick this is like
it was like a first grade like nah man
right
been there seen that also I got I got to
say no to God today I guess that's
that's wild oh yeah if they get like the
the like some ps4 vs. xbox limited time
events like that
that's that'd be really cool I'd like it
oh why is the alpha 4 2 V 2 is not
coming to the PC beats me you have to
ask Infinity Ward about that I'm
guessing it might have to do with them
kind of leaning more towards the ps4 for
for whatever deals are doing we won but
I carried that time alright let me go
see if I can invite
count is a loss sorry over can't believe
this alright alright see I guess you
press the friends button invite the
party party invite sent so it's weird
that they're calling parties and then
party chats being two separate things is
kind of like a weird I feel like they
need more of like a way to tell them
apart how can I in someone's in my lobby
that's a good question I don't think
he's ever imagined oh there yeah that's
how you tell number of players 24 Eric
where you at maybe he gave up and he's
like I'm gonna go get food from the food
trucks oh snap join the party
oh yeah food truck Friday yeah I'm very
excited for that I'm always excited for
a briefing what's the weapon count so
far I haven't done like an official
count but there are quite a few weapons
you get to mess around with in this
alpha which is kind of cool like almost
every loadout has either like a
completely different weapon or a weapon
that's been altered by like putting
different attachments on it it's like
there's there's one word like you'll get
the two shot shotgun and then there's
another one where they put like a scope
on it and like do something with the
barrel to make it kind of have a longer
range and it functions completely
differently so there's there's there's
variety in there
see ya like search-and-destroy is one of
my favorite game modes so I think that's
why I'm really enjoying this alpha
because you know pretty much has all
search industry elements without the
bomb yeah without searching and
destroying all right one more everything
come on come on there we go
oh he's got that that good that good
animated emblem it's ready to go
so I muted everyone once and now every
person that comes in everyone's
permanently muted alright
Tate Tate instantly says carry me sure
for the carry you know they're gonna cut
that way someone has to hold just like
hit darkness do you like that Tay I
can't believe it I do like the more
casual grenade throws in this one that's
that's a pretty cool thing as I was
warming up she's gonna get past these
two rounds of like snipers oh there is
the other guy I don't know everyday yeah
radar
scope is just so obnoxious there's those
jump scares again every time never
prepared ok surrounding snow this is
kind of like having Taylor stream
because get to watch him play and I'm
going to say that just loud enough so
that if he's watching the stream you can
hear me say it and then he becomes very
aware of the fact that we're all
watching him definitely won't make him
feel knew he was on top of it we
watching so we've we've got our good pal
Tay out out in the the office who has
joined her game and he is hanging out so
when we die it'll automatically switched
to him told to you in minecraft or
horror games to true Lauren's time we
had to go to a friend's house to play
multiplayer games like I do and I still
do that sometimes
it's alright sorry still still the
warm-up match like we're just getting
getting set up to tase tase just come in
we still got yeah yeah yeah you got a
rocket launcher now that's everything's
fine
this is OK can't wait for shadow keep
I'm actually pretty excited for shadow
keep - I don't play much destiny anymore
but I like what's going on with Bungie
right now
Erik's playing from the food truck this
is just sitting there actually his
name-o you find the tree I know not hit
him right on the nose
Oh first fire alrighty then just people
were saying earlier that burst fire is
really good there it is there it is oh
no I don't know where you shot him from
health is pretty evenly matched - oh no
of course I guess wrong I wasn't Jerry
Erickson behind
I have no ps4 so Sanford well I mean at
least at least were able to sit here and
like hang out with you and maybe answer
questions for you if you can't get your
hands on the the Alpha to play it
yourself so I want to help help people
out help you learn about the games you
want to play is this the only game mode
in the Alpha yes it's only the 2v2 gun
fight do watching from the jihad
watching Persia play it's I'm I was too
afraid to play call of duty on the
stream so i'm i'm just here
here to talk all right
Eric we gotta bring this back but I got
that assumes you SMG life going on it's
the SMG rounds I love it when is this
officially releasing the back of my mind
thinks October 2 but I don't remember
this specific date you play a split
screen not this alpha and I'm not sure
about the actual game that was
definitely a headshot like 200% Nicki's
so Katie's on the case yeah all right
all right how do you have a benefit like
Blake's breakthrough mode I hope I don't
think they've announced anything for it
but yeah I'm not a big fan of science
well captain price be a killstreak he
just shows up and like kind of it kind
of twirls his moustache and disappears
we're okay he got him other Eric says
hello from Indonesia hello welcome to
the stream it's good to see you and have
you here can't get over the gun audio
yeah the audio sounds really good in
this game alright give him a proper
English welcome
October 25th Jedi Knights confirming so
you you you had it you knew it oh you
pulled your weight though you you got
that that one guy he'd even know you
were there oh he shed a diet you robbed
the bold hip fires I love it Oh who's
gonna peek first whoever peeks first is
gonna gonna get it oh I need to I need
the run back I need to see what happened
there that was the most that was lucky
I've seen in this entire time in this
beta in that I don't think he was even
cited up the gun was coming down he just
pulled the trigger wasn't my proudest
moment it's fine how do you sprint
faster you DoubleTap spring oh yeah yeah
those first few rounds are rough we had
like sniper my sniping skills in
cottages not good I don't have the
patience for it yes that's why I love
the the SMGs because they they shoot
fast there's more bullets out at the
same time they're smaller so you can run
around a lot more definitely not a
sniper rifle type which is like the
complete antithesis of what that is
this shotgun is a beast
I'm gonna try to get close enough to use
it I think that guy oh I thought his
teammate laughs I was like that's
unfortunate Thanks
dang I was waiting dang he definitely
hurt me the first shot whew
the reload animations are pretty
realistic yeah I also kind of like the
like just the kind of idle animations
for guns in this a lot cuz they're not
like you don't have your gun up
perfectly the whole time levels it's
kind of off the side until you pulled up
to actually shoot oh but he did it yeah
you got it
heck yeah I thought it was being smiled
like you know what let me check the
flank just these guys going around
oh that's the Call of Duty classic the
second look away is the second they show
up how you actually do a fusion I don't
think you do finishers in this game you
can melee people though that's pretty
close to like your finisher is true
Sebastian calls out that pub goes
getting that crossover cross-play to you
imagine walking up to a person who's
holding that up like I love you yeah
when you know that that's your equipment
you're you're in a good place it's your
friendly fire on I don't know I don't
think so otherwise probably been
flashing teammates a lot when I've been
playing
Oh freakin owned me ah
snipers Bob I also like not just the the
death animation but also like the fact
that like gun just flips away there's
there's a lot of like kind of
over-the-top dramatic things that
happened that I'm really feeling dang Oh
apparently if you melee from behind you
can do like a finishing move that's
exciting
I'm down for that oh no I should have
turned that way sooner did sooner
oh dang all right well we got now okay
and people heck yeah this is a good
loadout you got a desert eagle and you
got a an mp5 that's the stuff perfect oh
he was in it he was trying to make some
plays des he wants to know if we could
say what's up gamers not on ironically
tell you that much all three knife is
really cool too and it's still you know
just as good like it bounces off the
floor and can still kill you hey tech
Aaron looks like they're hungry that's
unfortunate okay
yeah the throwing animations are very
very casual which I kind of dig but
No okay take him and just swept it up
yeah four to five they're on match point
we got collections out yeah invite for
duel but we've already got to do a
partner I'm sure you're looking for
someone in the chat I think you can
shoot through that middle well ruff it's
fine you can't win I think of the three
maps I played so far that one's probably
my favorite yeah I like that one a lot I
also like the one that's indoors the
forest one not so much I characters and
we're going on a really good monitor so
that's obviously just a me problem okay
cool sounds good got time for one more
all right this this is the last one
let's hey this is it we gotta make it
count but we've got a half an hour
before we're done here still thinking
about those food trucks still still
think about what's what's gonna go on
with that but in the meantime since
we're between matches if you guys do
like what you see and I hope you do if
you definitely subscribe to the channel
so you don't miss a single show that we
do stream every weekday at 11 a.m.
Pacific and we hope that you'll join us
for things in the future today Friday is
usually a community day with Sean nuke
and I or whoever else in the office is
into playing whatever game we're playing
unfortunately we can't like invite
people to the call duty beta and the
Call of Duty Vedas or alphas too much to
ignore and not play on the day that it
came out
so we had to make a bit of a an
exception I guess to play some Call of
Duty but we're still here hanging out
with you guys
oh there's that back flip again look
that in place back flip that's the sheer
force of the bullet it really is
Chris has the same light hammer leaving
him saw yeah she's she went on to work
it not sure she's she has gone away
though but she's still good friends
still still talk about cool game things
but yeah so no she's having a good time
so well like that that bit of a warning
shot where all the bullets definitely
just whizzed past his head got in he had
to have like no time to react Oh cuz he
was trying to throw something at you
trying to hit me or the Molotov yeah you
get you can't invite people on your
friends list you can invite I don't know
if you can invite people for a full game
but you can definitely get like a
teammate who's playing right now
purge is playing working it this five
and OH run
pretty well this game they they didn't
know what hit them
we were getting some good load outs in
the beginning all the trade oh I didn't
see him at all
losing at this guy oh shoot
tase tase got the strats
oh I did taste like king of trades right
now he's doing it oh you definitely hit
someone yeah Spencer small oh we want to
make sure that you see enough of the
game yeah it's actually not in a good
spot to be honest that's covering let's
see the actual like score that's right
we can shout it out let people know no
we're too far into it at this point I
could move it but yeah heck yeah what up
hey DG stay oh don't get locked in okay
I got us out unless he wants to play
another one he might he might be heading
off to get those uh sweet food trucks
yeah I can invite my friend play with me
yeah we just invited a friend to come
and play with us a little while ago or
for a bit
still still here he hasn't left yet
oh there was a button I saw oh my gosh
I'm lost
yeah it's it's working a new menu see ya
alrighty play the game modes we would
love to if we could but this is the only
mode available in the Alpha and you know
that we're gonna play it and we're
probably going to try to play with you
guys in community Fridays so you can
show us create you are at the new Call
of Duty game it'll be a good time for
you reads from Ireland Switzerland
people I'm all over the place that
hanging out I love it
happy Friday yeah yeah time zones are
another thing as this beta gonna be free
the beta is free anymore apparently you
don't need plus even to play it you just
go and find it download it really do
that thing come on beat it looks having
a hard time finding people
[Music]
there we go yeah they really should do a
cross play beta because I just want to
see how it works no it's the force push
up my glasses try to look very intense
from South Africa shot South Africa
hanging out still Friday for a few hours
oh yeah there you go Kim feels like
you're playing hardcore I do like
playing hardcore in and call duty fairly
often but it does have a bit of a
hardcore feel to it Wow take a moment to
breathe yes this alpha is ps4 only at
the moment I don't know why they chose
to do that but that's what we're dealing
with
yeah the marker was pointing towards
like the middle of the map a little bit
of a slide going there your phone bag is
the beta free I don't know
I'm assuming you talked about like the
beta you get from like pre-ordering or
something right
I should probably like call duties
coming up I should probably figure out
what's going on with that cuz I'm
probably gonna need to play the beta and
also get ready to play the game betas
not free singing saying
Oh oh my goodness Victor Zsasz hi new
welcome welcome
happy rear piecework gets the beta early
- can't believe it all the perks some
modern warfare over some World War 2
graphics the actual World War two are
like the game world war 2 called in
world war ii actually looked pretty
alright favorite weapons so far I'm
diggin the mp5 whenever I get it there
was also like a like a small like
machine pistol I got that had like a
drum magazine on it and I don't remember
what was we've said a few times already
it is only 2 V 2 and that the actual
title of the Alpha is the 2d 2 alpha mp7
mp7 is a good time
I like the shotguns too like shotguns
are always a good kind of like fallback
for me but I'm a submachine gun guys -
is the melee back to being a one-shot
you don't have the knife kill anymore
but any time I've made someone they've
died it's definitely a one-hit kill from
behind melees two hits there you go
alright
it's officially a new favorite game
channel heck yeah
that makes me really happy to hear cuz
there are a lot of really cool people
here who do a lot of really good work
and they try to make sure you guys have
cool things to look at and in fact that
you like it it makes me and all of them
very happy you just want to hang out and
talk about games sites just camping I
mean you are in the woods and what are
you doing the woods you got a camp oh
hey how's it going how do you aim in
without the scope you just pull up
they're gonna do the iron sights how's
that knee shot alright pistol rounds are
over
dang it's alright we got this think like
the only kill I even have this round was
from Jack and anyways
heck yeah
whistles I just struggle sometimes yeah
Bob Jones's for calling a simpler time
when in one of the modern warfare games
had multiplayer builds you just run
around melee people with no guns six it
sounds is a good time the first thing
that I thought of was modern warfare 2
because you get the attack knife
attachment for a pistol and you could
have like Marathon Pro and yeah this is
fine like marathon pro in something else
and it would actually extend the
distance that you'd block on you could
literally fly across the air and just
instant stab people I felt bad because I
did like uh cuz I love metal gear and I
was like I'm gonna do a Solid Snake
builder he has a SOCOM pistol and attack
knife because I love Snake Eater and it
end up being like the metaphor the first
like couple of months in the game okay
come play airsoft with us I used to do a
lot of airsoft back when I lived back in
in Michigan but I don't do that much
anymore because now I work I have a job
I mean I'm in California I guess apex
has me spoiled I always just run up to
every rock and I'm like holding X to
climb over it yeah commando there you go
so as marathon pro for like endless
sprinting so you could just whip around
corners and then commando for for the
lunging so I'm pretty I think that was
modern warfare 2
think Adam yeah dang we brought it back
it's five five no boo brings up a good
point something that we actually
encountered earlier in the stream for
people who are there and you might
recall when it comes down to an overtime
and you have more or less health than
the other team that's what determines
the win and we ended up dang that was
cold-blooded uh sure
cool we had one health difference it was
99 to 100 and we ended up losing because
that was bad I don't know why so trying
to challenge that I was stunned see
truly they showed five maps so I only
see three of them sir only put three in
the Alpha I guess unless we just haven't
gotten the other ones by chance because
I was playing for a few like hours this
morning or not really that long about
play few games and I played I don't know
maybe five or six games before I even
played on the third map which is the
indoors one so yeah I like it I'm
looking forward to this game coming out
yeah I'm excited to play it as well I've
seen the games about nerf videos and not
to mention the rocket League one that
rocket League one is legendary it's
fantastic oh whoa we've actually been
going for an hour and fifty minutes I
forgot that we started earlier yeah a
plan gamepad you betcha
that's the PlayStation 4 it's happening
what what am i searching still I think
so can you shoot through walls galaxies
yes yes they still have the material
penetration that they've been kind of
doing for like since since modern
warfare called it before I think
but yeah I'm curious about this Lobby
screen like my character is just
infinitely walking she looks so nervous
debris and rubble all alone by proximity
is making me nervous
yeah what's happening here connecting to
matchmaking service
sure what if what if it just kind of has
fallen apart what if everyone's got
everyone went home early on Friday and
they're all trying to play call of duty
Chris Pat brings up the PS 5 dev kit
have you seen the the pictures of that
that have been going around I have not
oh so apparently they they had like
these pictures of what the dev kit for
ps5 looks like like leaked out somewhere
and then someone apparently just was
like yeah this is it this is what we
actually have in the office it looks
like this thing looks wild
it's got like it like like weird fender
things it's but def gets usually kind of
look weird or wild but yeah if the
server's went down an aisle this stores
currently unavailable thank God more
important question regular multiplayer
they still have I I think they still
have the factions cuz you'll see like we
have the British ones that pop up when
we were on the forest I just don't have
a good group of maps to pull from but
yeah
been cool to have more variety in the
Alpha Maps yeah I agree Ryan maybe
something more to kind of just show off
more of how the the possibilities in the
maps are gonna because these are all
like good examples of ah a classic three
way through like map that you're
definitely in a play and is gonna be
there but maybe something exciting
something something different would be
good they're scared they want to fight
me I I'm afraid to suggest it but what
if we backed out to the main menu or
maybe restarted the game like how'd it
reconnect to the the servers like
full-on there we go searching for a
match now cool that's that's progress
perfect the good ol like that was
equivalent to like the time plug back in
turn the off turn back on yeah back out
all right let's do this I want to play
that indoor map haven't played in a
while I like this one too yeah this
one's pretty good and they have one guy
Oh No there is
I do appreciate that in this lick first
round countdown they're like this is
where the flag is gonna be if it comes
down to it this is where the other
people are gonna be starting off like
basically across the map from you it's
all good yeah I mean that oh I thought
he died okay oh my that was the last
shot in that magazine I think it was a
headshot no was that shot but still uh I
was about to be like man that's real
bold move not reloading after you got
that kill it takes a lot of willpower to
not do that oh so you're you're three up
right now you're totally fine you're
pulling your pulling your weight in you
boost yeah I agree I really like the the
time to kill on this game it feels about
right with almost every weapon that I've
I've been using heroes those the shots I
like the little like panic melee that
they did as they were falling yes that's
good all right burst fire you gotta
remember that
what up gamer or something how's it
going oh my goodness right off the bat
gadem just take the whole thing I just
run the whole game he was waiting for me
to go the other way yeah
was it possible to turn the motion blur
off there might be an option for it but
I don't I haven't like looked through it
too much outside of changing my my aim
assists I haven't really dug too much
into it
sandwiched oh wow yeah yeah the sound is
also very good
Ryan's mentioning I'm I still want to
like get my hands on that twenty v20
motor I want to see what they're doing
to kind of step into battlefields area
that's that's the thing I'm really
excited about an info on the modern
warfare having a battle royale I I know
as much as you do there's a part of me
that kind of hopes that it doesn't
because like I kind of want us to as a
whole move past the Battle Royale craze
a bit I feel like I myself personally am
over it and I'm fine with what we have
but unless someone does something
totally crazy or different I'm just kind
of like terminal high-rise both
fantastic maps also hi cyborg I'm gonna
see it is this game out already one can
I purchase it it's not out yet this is a
free 2 V 2 multiplayer alpha that you
can download and play over this weekend
if you want to get your hands on it and
see what the new Call of Duty is about
yeah that was a very fortunate shot
yikes
struggling oh oh you saw me too crap
like obviously like if they do decide to
put a battle royale on this I probably
try it a bit but like I don't know if
all I get into it yeah honestly God
doesn't need it yeah I mean battle
royale was pretty good in black ops and
it was interesting to kind of see that
work out rushed it my teammate got
smoked early someone say he does a real
slide yeah yeah you were carrying in
just nothing there in terms of help has
anyone gotten 17 kills yet I haven't I'm
not I'm not that good like if it goes
all the way down to the last round and
you get every kill probably the only way
yeah are you excited for mana Matt Dan
yes I love on till dawn and I will make
very excited to play Manomet Dan all the
dark pictures bits I want more of that
stuff come on you this give us that
indoor map I don't even remember what
it's called yeah so speed walls the name
of the one we were just on oh alright I
can't believe this going back out to the
woods again blackout was using yeah I
feel like at the time blackout happened
it might have been my favorite version
of battle royale just because it felt
familiar because of playing so much Call
of Duty but still kind of was its own
deal
yeah man I'm I don't I'm kinda like
checked out maybe framerate a ps4 is
disgusting this room rater seems fine
oh you mean you just stood like a blind
shot and you just send up like I was
running that way and then I kind of
thought wow yeah that's praising see me
yes I'm seeing a lot of people talk
about errors popping up with them trying
to play in I'm not sure what that is
maybe there's something on like the Call
of Duty Twitter maybe they're they're
addressing it I'm sure I'm sure they're
whatever errors are happening they've
got to be working on because this it's a
test for them and they want to see that
many people didn't do it started to Troy
coming around that's about to break it
down we're about to have to capture that
flag he's already in there oh oh he
knows he's over there he had the jump on
him and everything what are you doing no
watch like it time was almost out and
you had the life lead and I was like
just run but then he clutched it out
yeah that's kind of hate that it's face
off like you're home
went to him yeah my sensitivity is
actually when I open it it was already
on to sensitive like when I started the
game I don't know
yeah the default I think it's lower used
to be 3 as the default steadily the guy
that's not here I am very excited for
cyberpunk the game looks fantastic and I
can't wait to see what's going on with
it
customizable yeah there's like a like a
gunsmith mode where you can like do a
lot of changing for your guns excited
Yipes
I'm really excited to see this this
final kill camera away from outside the
man dang that's crazy
but I think I think the games that I'm
most excited for for the rest of this
year are like I'm excited to get my
hands on Borderlands I'm excited to play
the we just mansion because I like
Luigi's Mansion a lot doom dooms really
big I do might be the the highest thing
for me right now that I can at least
think of off the top of my head
with the Rockets oh heck yeah nice just
like that
oh my wrap it up like read fall
I actually didn't notice greed fall too
much until we saw the gamescom trailer
that happened this week and I was like
oh wait a minute this is like some
Dragon Age type of stuff like I'm way
into this so I don't know if how much
we're in the open I'm sure we'll we'll
cover it I'll probably play it
we had s training just ranting and in
doom chopper gameplay a real bad it's a
game about deliveries and making
connections with people bring people
together social strings
it's a strand game the Strand genre this
is my garbage excuse of trying to say
that I totally get Jima in a weird way
and I can't explain it
yeah I know I'm I'm very excited for
that game I'm very excited for doom oh
no how do you mind me find us dude oh oh
man those are just really quick
oh man yeah like I was all up in our
base there's ups simulator there you go
got to get the package there on time I
mean it might end up being that Chris
like it might actually just be the
ultimate walking simulator walking
simulator isn't necessarily like a like
a negative thing like I like a lot of
the what consider where people consider
to be walking simulator games heck yeah
oh yeah that was the last round say we
were actually yeah we could probably
wrap it up here I think totally uh I'm
excited for food trucks let's do that
alright drop you guys try to play this
alpha this weekend before it goes away
super worth oh there we go I hit the
right button this time we're doing it
anyway thank you guys so much for
hanging out with us and I hope you had a
great time and thank you for hanging out
and working all the people in these
lobbies with your clutch shooting
ability appreciate very much you know
I'm enjoying the outside so I would
recommend it if you guys are cod fans so
yeah have a happy Friday and a good
weekend you guys we'll see you next week
bye everybody
I'm gonna find these buttons and I'm
gonna definitely close this out the
right way that's not the one I want to
do where's the outro button it's right
here I totally have it trust me is it
this one
[Music]